well hey there buckaroos that's the
voice of Woody but it's not who you
think it is
howdy I'm Jay Steele and today I'm here
with the voice of a legendary Cowboy
who's been in toys theme parks live
shows computer games and video things
and Jim just he works on those all year
long it's the legendary voice of Woody
Jim Hanks thanks for joining me Jen
legendary oh let no doubt come on okay
all right all right so how many years
wait 28 29 years I think 29. wow okay I
went and did the first toy in 94 before
the first movie came out so did I get
everything on the list I got the toys
theme park like you've done your career
is extensive with Woody I did one uh
short after the fourth movie came out
called Lamplight yes okay and that was
the voice there yeah more or less I was
like going oh okay I'm actually doing
real stuff now animated by Pixar right
yeah all the way so let's go back to the
beginning how did you become the voice
my agent basically said Disney wants to
you to go in and do this stuff and this
thing your brother's doing and okay I
don't remember actually auditioning I
just remember going into this tiny
little booth and having a little bit of
a scratch of you know Tom having done it
Sarge you seen Slinky yeah I think I had
I don't know seven eight lines a good
classic you're my favorite Deputy hey
howdy hey snake in my boot sure I'd like
to join your Posse boys but first I'd
like to sing you a little song a few
things like that and uh walked out and
went fine well that's cool
29 years later I'm still doing it so I'm
I feel incredibly fortunate
at the time or before that did you know
you could do that voice you could hit it
I never really knew that my voice was as
similar to Toms I have since then seen
videos of myself probably I'll do it
here too uh where I watch myself and go
oh my God yeah I do sound like him even
if I'm not trying but no I was never
going hey Tom say that again Tom does
this thing
where he simultaneously pushes with its
diaphragm and he pushes it up to his
nose so I'm talking like this but Tom
talks like this he's like here at the
same time it's down deep but it's also
up here hi I'm Tom
and and for me whenever I'm at a mic and
I'm finding uh I go hey hey hey hey and
I can find him I find that that the hay
has an explosiveness that takes me too
Tom especially early on Woody has a lot
of power
I've always said that
my woody is my impression of Tom yelling
at his kid okay it's like get down from
there that's that is that is Woody
the same thing yeah always straining
together yeah yeah and it when it's like
that it it'll blow you out fast when
toys come to life oh infinity and beyond
Toy Story when you were going into the
first project had you heard of Toy Story
like what were their trailers out at the
time or no okay no I think it was far
enough Advance because they were making
the toy and I think the first three toy
stories came out on Thanksgiving Happy
Thanksgiving set right before Christmas
and people oh my God every oh yeah Toy
Story toy I did know that Tom was doing
something and at the time you know Pixar
was what the tin toy and a couple things
I mean not very many people knew who
Pixar was
or even what CG animation was right yeah
computer generate oh that's gonna look
weird well Disney pictures presents the
first ever computer animated motion
picture event is that the beginning of
an era and for me it's been really
fortunate that for whatever reason Woody
has become one of their more iconic
characters and so one of the things
that's fortunate for me is that they
will ask the Woody character to do a lot
of different things coming up what is
yours now oh really I think the voice
for this do I really have to stand in
line and there's also a word that
they're thinking about making more don't
touch that dial we'll be right back what
he's round up after this brief message
tasteify has done collabs with many
brands in the past including Toy Story
and their latest collabs with Spider-Man
and I will say Spider-Man X case defy
may be the best collab yet like all cage
defy cases these have drop protection
but this time with some of the most
unique designs yet the textures
especially on these two mirror cases are
awesome and really pop in person there's
also clear cases that showcase
Spider-Man swinging and a collage Daily
Bugle articles these are all my personal
favorites but there's many more to
choose from including a whole Venom
collection so check out the entire
Spider-Man X case defy collection by
clicking the link in the video
description below and I want to thank
case defy for sponsoring this video and
now let's get back to it do you know
what the first project you did was it
the toy you said that yeah the first
pool toy was the first one the talking
and possible figures of Woody and Buzz
Lightyear my name's Woody sold
separately I think the second one
was the ice capades oh the Disney on Ice
stuff yeah I've heard you have to like
enunciate more and like project because
you're in a huge Arena well enunciation
uh was really important at the beginning
because like even the pull toy was kind
of mushy sounding compared to what they
have now oh okay so I did have to say
there's a snake in my boot and hit the T
really hard and things like that because
it comes out you know so you have to
really uh it really enunciate and yeah
you have to over enunciate because it's
in this giant Auditorium with a lot of
ice so that the sound is bouncing around
weird but you know painful part of
singing
the first time was absolutely terrifying
oh God I'm not a singer okay and it was
the music because you're in a different
voice it's not really you singing well
that actually when I did the ice capades
it was terrifying and I was just I just
got through it it wasn't until I did uh
the the Woody with the guitar strumming
singing Woody and he sings home in the
rain
[Applause]
I was struggling through that and it was
same kind of thing I was trying to sing
well which
was not gonna happen
and uh at some point I just went hold on
let me just try this more in character
then that was it
that was the time where I got it yeah so
that so that was like you know kind of a
landmark going oh I can do this yeah all
right cool howdy Partners climb aboard
we were recording the Midway Mania and I
was like on my third
uh session
you know and sometimes sessions go for
you know four or six hours so it could
be pretty intense they were really
having a hard time because they kept
saying Woody has to be able to talk to
two and three-year-olds I was trying to
do everything I could and there was a
couple of little examples in the movies
where he's hey buddy hey buddy come on
kind of thing and uh it just wasn't
working and we were like in the third
session
and I went can I say something and they
went yeah what I said the thing about
Woody is Woody never talks down to
anybody Woody to me is like everybody's
favorite teacher who talks to you as a
person and they went okay let's try that
and I did the entire ride in 45 minutes
because if we just did it like that yes
it just shows like you have the voice
but you know the character integrity to
keep it going you know that's awesome
have you been to um you gotta have been
to Disneyland at Disney world to see
I've only been to Disneyland yeah okay I
have not been to Disney World I've been
in Saw Toy Story Land and you're right
up in Center yeah 50 foot tall Woody
yeah he's not the biggest one oh there's
a I think it's a hundred foot tall one
in Hong Kong oh another Woody yeah wow
they showed me pictures of everyone
that's a little scary yeah and your
voice is booming throughout the whole
land I'd like to give you a nice big
Andy's backyard welcome what was it like
going on Midway Mania yes that's so
weird yeah this is so weird yeah you're
in what the project you are like you're
playing it you're in the ride you're
yeah what was that like yeah I just go
stop telling me what to do
oh I'm talking to myself
uh yeah it's it's trippy and it's it's
always trippy there was a a time in the
early 2000s I was also the voice of Toys
R Us Jeffrey The Jerk that's right hello
welcome to Toys R Us can I help you my
everywhere wow wow Jeffrey dolls but my
voice came out of I'm on the PA system
or I could walk over and start pulling a
string on a Woody doll that was all over
the place the king of Toys R Us
that was a great job and it always
cracks me up when somebody says oh I
went to Disneyland when I was coming
next you were everywhere do you have any
Disney perks when you go to the parks
one time we were there shortly after
Midway Mania show started and it was
just you know I like that all these
people you see behind me are here for
the grand opening of Toy Story Mania and
we hear it's a five hour wait in line
and I walked up to one of the persons
went hey um
I did the voice for this do I really
have to stand in line and they went
and so they disappear and then somebody
with the you know one of the jackets
shows up and go okay Mr Hanks here no so
that was kind of cool that was the only
time I pulled that that's awesome so
yeah we got okay theme parks Ice shows
how about the video games
I feel like those would be really
difficult so you have I'm sure a ton of
lines for every situation the character
can be in and how about the efforts like
when you get oh yeah the efforts are
yeah you explain what those are it's
just the sounds like okay he's landing
and okay you know and we need it like
he's Landing from 10 feet to just
jumping off a curb so it's like uh
[Music]
you know air everything in between and I
remember going in and working on one
it's the first time I ever met John
ratzenberger which was really great he's
a super nice guy oh you look good hey
you lose some weight but I I go in and
you know and that was old style you know
very two-dimensional he's just running
from one side to this you're not really
into it like you know like the Kingdom
Hearts thing which is amazing but I
remember one point it says okay now he's
going to climb up this rope and then
he's going to jump over here then he's
going to kick this thing off off the and
the long list of things I had to do I
said I'm scratching okay
and action
and I do this whole thing and I'm
watching the guys in the room just going
foreign
all right I'm doing it right yeah one
take wonder you got it yeah it was it
was yeah it was fun we leave all the
explosive stuff like the efforts and the
yeehaws are I always do at the end
because it could be kind of rough on
your voice and stuff like that with
meeting John ratzenberger have you ever
recorded with anyone else in the cast or
is it always alone it's almost always
alone
um I did not record with him there was
one time we did it and it was for
Saturday morning interstitials we're
Claire good
and that one was fun because they had
everybody who was doing it and there was
this one guy who they had kind of
stretched you know the shark who finds
his hat gone
give me that they made his character and
they did it where he was Robert Shaw
from Jaws
his batteries were dead
that's so funny that's great oh my God
it was so funny oh so that one you did
with the game yeah we were all in the
group he's just sitting there and he's
telling his story it was so hard to not
just absolutely crack up it was so fun
so we have Toy Story one through four do
you ever go back and record like
specific lines from one or specific from
four and is there a difference between
those kids yeah 29 years yeah there is I
recently did a thing I forget what the
project was but I was doing like it
sound alike for all these different
lines that came out of all the four
movies and so starting in one and I have
to be young Tom you know and and then
I'm getting these directions going for
the lines from you know four or three uh
Jim can you get a little closer to Old
Tom here it's like well that's a weird
Direction you can't teach this old toy
new tricks if you if you notice he's
having more conversations that aren't
powerful yeah he's not trying to control
the room you know kind of find everyone
moving buddy you haven't found one get
one now he's having conversations where
he's just kind of sitting with my hands
so what happened to you but so how long
were you in here I would think with uh
with all the everything you've done with
all the different categories that it's
more prevalent when a new movie comes
out is it like oh like really crazy hour
and four came out yeah 19 or 18 whenever
the the year The Lap four came out was
crazy because then they do all the
commercial tie-ins and stuff like that
it's all clear
those are always good years it's slowed
down a little bit but it's been picking
up again and there's also a word they're
thinking about making more I don't know
where they're going to go with it but
those people from Pixar are freaking
Geniuses so I'm going to assume it's
going to be something really cool and I
remember after four
granted this has changed now but after
four I was having lunch with Tom and we
were talking about talking you know and
he you know he thought he was done he
said well what is yours now oh really
well I guess it is isn't it okay but not
so much
and he's back
I'm doing it no no I feel like your your
legacy with Woody is just Monumental
because of how many things you've done
and how prevalent your voice is I think
two uh you know
some of it is Tom's Fame you know I'm
you know Tom I I say this often Tom is
arguably one of the most famous people
on the planet
so
that has something to do with it you
know and Pixar again Geniuses Tom wasn't
he was successful but he wasn't who he
is now yeah well to end off the
interview since you said that you do
yeehaws at the end do you mind saying
bye to it to the viewers and giving us a
little yee-haw I'm going to have to
moisturize her first I haven't tried it
so okay okay
and normally I can get high but it's
just not going to happen no that was it
that sounded exactly like it
well hey there buckaroos it's been a
great show so we'll see you next time
same Cowboy Time same Cowboy Channel
tune in next week for the exciting
conclusion what is by the shower I'm one
time Tom and I were up visiting my
mother and we called my other brother
we're just blabbing away my brother
Larry finally says I I just got to say
this is like listening to Dueling
Woodies
okay that's great
foreign